another migrant caravan from Central
America making its way to our southern
border it's a massive about a thousand
people across from Honduras into
Guatemala on Monday night the president
responded today on Twitter to all this
he said this quote the United States has
strongly informed the president of
Honduras that if the large caravan of
people heading to the US is not stopped
and brought back to Honduras no more
money or aid will be given to Honduras
effective immediately
that threat may have worked at least in
the short term Guatemalan authorities
say they are arresting the caravans
leader and plan to deport him back to
Honduras
Davida furries of learn a foreign policy
expert for the Obama campaign
well-versed in international law and the
politics of Central America we also also
note that he is a apparently registered
foreign agent for the government of El
Salvador David thanks for joining us
tonight why is that not exactly the
response that every president ought to
give when a foreign country in attempts
a kind of invasion well here's here's
why so we have every right to protect
our border and we don't have to let any
of these migrants in but if the goal is
for them not to come here we should not
be cutting off foreign aid to Honduras
Honduras is getting that aid from the US
so we can help improve the economy in
Honduras and the reason these people are
leaving Honduras is because the economy
is terrible and there are no jobs these
are economic refugees and the reason
they're trying to come to the u.s. is
they're looking for a better life so if
in the long term if we don't want them
to come we have to try to work with
Honduras and the other countries in
Central America to improve their
economies so that people stay ok so how
is that working for us so we've given
obviously a lot of aid tell Salvador
over the years one third of all
Salvadorans on the planet now live in
the United States one third of all
existing Salvadorans so clearly
everything we've done for Salvador
hasn't stopped the flow of one third of
their entire population into our country
so like that this actually works so why
not just say look rich people who run
third world country we're going to
punish you personally if you let this
crap continue
I don't why is that a bad idea we
haven't given very much money to Central
America now keep in mind we all give
about 1% of our
overall two in foreign aid around the
world just a very small amount of that
goes to Central America look at the
Marshall Plan that unfortunately how
much goes to outweigh would hold on hold
on
let me give any one third of all
Salvadorans live in our country okay a
lot of them illegally and I'm sure
they're all great people I'm not
attacking them I'm merely saying this
arrangement isn't working they're
offloading their poor into our country
at a time when working-class jobs are
going away due to automation they're
benefiting we're losing and we're still
paying them so I just this I just
explained that to you and the reason
that we're giving aid is to help improve
those countries so that people stay
that's the long-term goal I think you
and I both agree on that as do you know
many policymakers here in Washington we
haven't I don't because I've done a good
enough job neither Democrats nor
Republicans have done a good enough job
of helping these countries improve their
economies helping these countries
improve the rule of law
and Mexico has jumped more than ten
spots on the economic development list
internationally I think it's now number
eleven we've made Mexico rich with trade
billions and billions of dollars
millions of jobs and yet we still have
22 million people in this country
legally the majority the Mexican so I'm
not attacking Mexico or Mexican people
I'm just saying we've made Mexico way
richer than it was and we still have an
inflow from Mexico so like we're not
getting anything out of this Tucker
that's a great example that's a great
example yes we are because far less
immigrants are coming from Mexico right
now you referred to immigrants that are
already here from Mexico many of whom
came a long time ago before the benefits
and after before the benefits of NAFTA
went in place so that's at the data we
do not get that many immigrants from
Mexico and even your example that we're
talking about today is migrants from
Honduras not from Mexico they're gonna
be New Mexico they're innocents Mexicans
who are enjoying the benefits of NAFTA
are gainfully employed we're supporting
their families
so the
I'm sorry example since you're using the
term data let me refer you to this
essential datum in this conversation
which was we have more than 10 million
Mexican citizens living in our borders
illegally once again not attacking them
but if the model that you're proposing
works and we both know that it doesn't
this is all a joke there's only a huge
lie the whole point is to make the
Democratic Party more powerful we both
know that but let's pretend let's just
play along if your model works then why
are they still here
why haven't they gone back to the newly
enriched Mexico which we enriched with
our money and our jobs well many way
Network many family here I'm ago the
data I'm referring to is over the last
few years
immigration illegal immigration from
Mexico has gone down you agree with me
about that right
well I'm missing it so we made Mex
you can see because then the data as you
said show that Mexico is way richer than
it was 20 years ago way richer we did
that we suffered as a result of that but
we also got all of their poor people who
they didn't feel like supporting with
their non-existent social safety net so
they can make more billionaires which
they have assiduously done and we get
shafted we're paying for health care of
their board people you don't see what
I'm talking about it all and no because
your point doesn't even make sense we're
talking about illegal migration right
and illegal immigration has gone down
for Mexico and it could go down for
Honduras and Guatemala and other
countries in Central America if we help
improve those economies we only give a
little bit of money so let's help
improve those economies so that you know
I think it's a really good game
john-boy's there and we need to pay more
so think about saying it's our fault
that's where they never said it son
thought I said we can help oh it's
totally our fault David thank you so
much thank you